- Okay. So it's time to
introduce our first guest.
And I don't know who it is.
I hope they like margaritas in case,
and if they don't, leave.
Please welcome the star
of one of my favorite shows on television.
Come on out, whoever you are.
(upbeat music playing)
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music continues)
Oh my gosh.
So basically, I'm on a date
drinking with Nathan Fillion.
That's what's happening, I'm just kidding.
- Are you surprised?
- I am, I had no, I literally
have nothing, no idea.
- We wanted to surprise you.
- Okay, okay.
- But I didn't want this
to be the only surprise.
- Oh it's enough.
- Can I bring some more?
- Oh yeah.
Oh, are you? Please say, okay.
- I want to you guys to all welcome,
please welcome, Mekia Cox.
- Yes.
- Melissa Diaz, Melissa
O'Neil and Eric Winter.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music playing)
- How are you doing?
(crowd cheering)